what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch Glass Onion and
knives out mystery knives out two Ryan Johnson
from The Last Jedi we like him here midnight
shoot and John came back from Colorado today
made it how are you I am good it was it was
a harrowing Adventure but I'm here and I'm
ready for Ryan Johnson you re-watch Knives
Out in the terminal you said yeah yeah that
was actually perfect I did not re-watch knives
out it's good we'll get some kind of perspective
well I'm a little bit bloated something went
wrong at the wedding I wasn't able to enjoy
the food that's a story for another time so
I treated myself last night but hey I'll get
my energy up in just a minute anyway guys
Cinema will pick you up leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated also full length
watch along as we sync up with your own copy
of Glass Onion available for super sexy rejects
thank you for everyone who supported us also
I've been wearing this shirt and videos recently
I haven't even shattered it out this is a
real rejects exclusive if anyone knows me
they know I hate the word influencer I constantly
like to clown on what an influencer is and
this is a shirt I've been wanting to make
for a long time so this is available at shopzeroedition.com
it's Rorschach from Watchman inspired of who
influences the influencers personally one
of my favorites just because this this one
means a lot to me for some reason so yeah
it's a great way to support the channel um
you go ahead and get yourself a shirt uh this
holiday season anywho let's watch glass on
you
foreign
thing and like now what's she running for
mayor of Westview and with me now is Connecticut
Governor Claire debella whose Senate campaign
is picking up steam oh it takes place during
the pandemic Uber for biospheres I don't know
okay maybe AI in dogs equals discourse it
does let's do it what no phones why can't
she have a phone because she's afraid that
I will tweet an ethnic slur
didn't even know that that word referred to
Jewish people I thought it was a generic term
for cheap oh
this is topical there's got to be a way to
open it it's solid there's no latches or even
visible seams the wood grain pattern's weird
though it's like it's familiar it's the lament
configuration and the answer is no Jimmy Kimmel
I do not hate boobs I mean there's nothing
wrong with that right babe I love my boobs
there's fun
[Music]
I've been calling you you gotta answer me
when I call will you shut it we've been over
this a million times I told you when me and
whiskey alive you gotta listen oh slap it
dookie I'm sorry you got a delivery it's in
the kitchen nice seeing him play against type
a little bit yeah my mom already broke it
it's a stereo Brown
stereogram were those the same Magic Eye things
whoa is that how those really work yeah like
those old books of the library [Music] damn
cool so it's it's set up for a maiden one
should I do it gasparah whoa maybe in one
of the other puzzles it's a compass ma it's
a compass I have loving the cast so far it's
music guys it's music it's music are you mocking
me yes when you layered this tune on top of
itself it starts to change and turns into
a beautiful new structure
cool all together now one two three [Music]
what is that
disruptors that's the Glass Onion well spotted
long weekend on my private island and I hope
your puzzle solving skills are wetted because
you will also be competing to solve the mystery
of my murder what's up I don't know somebody's
gonna make an actual like escape room puzzle
box out of that
hahaha get it
[Music] wow what a Time Saver she's like a
former lover of Miles she aware of the murderer
Among Us
everyone is sus IE what y'all trying to do
for me here we're worried about you buddy
you haven't left the bath for a week oh that's
hyperbole someone here for you the Box [Music]
dude nice this has a bit of a swashbuckling
Vibe all right Peter Steven Sondheim too crazy
little celebrity quadriforce there takes place
specifically in 2020 but feels like out of
an earlier era than even Knives Out was and
it's got like a more stylized kind of overall
package disruptor others have assembled absolutely
ladies and gentlemen whoa welcome to Greece
what my man I did not realize what the cast
was I know but first i'm gonna need you to
remove your mask and extend your tongue this
will only be momentarily uncovered wow I wonder
if he's got glass in those loafers that's
some kind of disinfectant you're good have
a great trip everyone that's the last we see
of Ethan Hawke you might be right I feel like
I could be
our Femme Fatale there's definitely like a
little bond in this you know I was thinking
that too yeah it's like bond in Indiana Jones
and Agatha Christie one legal move cut her
out completely booted her without a dime social
network
oh Eddie norden's miles whiskey wow I just
I love that necklace great
how are you doing uh what good friends Andy
and you're here I am all right
we got a great weekend just our gang just
us hey hey bro not here oh is that uh Noah
seagan a proper tour of the Glass Onion oh
yes here we go
like their bar yeah it's like an actual huge
Glass Onion it's what came before where I
am now what I'll leave to the world ignore
me
laughs I just want to have a normal weekend
with my old friends like the old days right
I mean [Laughter] I'm sorry but that is just
crazy I know hey Mr Blanc we have a quick
word so I'm gonna die what's the most impossible
scenario to do with it is that a motor car
oh yeah that's my baby blue it's one of a
kind goes anywhere I go why is it on the roof
I mean you received a box yes the wooden box
was delivered to my home with some it's part
of the game yeah is there any way to close
them again to to reset them someone reset
the Box someone reset the Box they sent it
to you who reset the box look at this pool
I think I'll go for a swim
that's their competition oh no maybe only
out for a bit
hey I want to look that good in anything believe
in yourself do you remember the night you
almost pancake me was it on the road outside
Anderson Cooper's birthday coops parties are
memorable maybe this isn't the MCU H really
Duke
you never know when shit's gonna go down fought
each other inspector
I preferred that
say I blame you oh whoa good reveal disruptive
what does that mean well some people think
Birdie's disruptive every time she opens her
mouth sure she was a fashion icon and then
the youngest editor ever of shishi magazine
then there was the whole thing with the Halloween
costume it was a tribute to Beyonce but people
did not take it that way oh God she blackface
it probably I'm gonna yeah if you want to
shake things up you break a norm or an idea
or a convention some little business model
but that's the place where you have to look
within yourself are you willing to break the
thing that nobody wants you to break yes sign
me up we all got to that line and crossed
it that's right Papa Elon knows who Lionel
works for that's no secret and we know who
bankrolled Claire's campaign nobody would
touch birdie with a 10-foot pole because she
went on Oprah and compared herself to Harriet
Tubman oh my God yeah when Duke got banned
from twitch for Hawking Rhino horn boner pills
to teenage boys with zero rhinos YouTube and
use their media Empire to promote the Stream
that is the common thread here every single
one of you is holding on for dear life to
Miles bronze golden titties
for myself well if miles is a system he must
be broken oh some people can't handle it it's
a dangerous thing the mistakes speaking without
thought for speaking the truth oh great luck
great luck [Laughter] I'm gonna post that
to my status
if you make her go through with it her name
is destroyed I'm sorry uh it is her only way
out
clearly have the means that's a great frame
less
find find the batteries take them out [Music]
I mean you must have seen this coming how
so many great lineup shots
oh my God it's so nice to hear this song in
a movie I love this song What
is
Jeremy renders small batch hot sauce I let
him invest he sends me like a palette every
year take a few bottles why would you hang
a framed print of the Mona Lisa front and
center it's like having a che poster in your
dorm it's the Mona Lisa you blame it on the
Pando Blanc louvers closed France needed money
and so I bought myself a little short-term
loan nice security because most of the cost
check this out oh my God
oh my gosh it's so freaking sensitive a phone
digs it closes up it's ridiculous but I needed
to be able to lick her in the eyes so much
glass it really is something it's classic
terrible I'm gonna unveil future use solid
hydrogen fuel it's incredibly powerful it's
radically efficient and it's derived from
abundant seawater call it clear with a k clever
with a K cool Claire and I are not going to
be responsible for putting something out in
the world before it is tested and
they're surrounded by it
if anyone can name the Killer tell me how
they achieved the murder and most importantly
what was the motive that person wins our game
what are we wearing what do you mean what
do you what do you want [Laughter] fine yeah
no no the winner gets an iPad no have we started
already is it well the murder hasn't happened
oh but
who planted a Remote device on a crossbow
in Revenge for you stealing her signature
Ren diamond oh God that is a vintage Jayhawk
brand crossbow Jayhawk buddy Jay Micah he's
doing it he's doing it whoa what became known
as the ren diamond and then that's a family
heirloom I believe to be clear I mean I didn't
know what a blood diamond was what would you
kindly open it for us woof
wow oh my God you're ruining the party give
the man an iPad you have two iPads
it's a perfect contrast first movie I just
felt like the most satisfied
here's the iPad I ruined your game on purpose
you've taken seven people each of whom has
a real life reason to wish you harm and place
the idea of your murder in their heads it's
like putting a loaded gun on the table and
turning off the lights it's protecting you
man sketched out the original idea for Alpha
on cocktail napkin and I showed it to Andy
one night at the Glass Onion how's our local
bar God damn I missed that bar well build
a new one you could build a hundred of them
so someone else has to die Maybe yeah miserable
in Paradise we've all earned this yes you
have [Laughter] [Music]
fine you got yours yours no he from me Claire's
trying to find us for sorry we feel bad for
you
I'm tired of pretending like you're the
thing you're the loser there that's the truth
that's cruel what is about to go down feel
the tension they're all about to die there
it is there's my guy what's going on you look
like you got good news I was wondering why
my goose are blowing up reviews on my channel
are off the charts you got to see this did
he record it's fire D it sure does I was like
this you buy those views you're staying yes
you're staying okay love you this feels more
like into the invitation than anything else
oh good good call yeah birdie that's amazing
just just watch this dress watch spin that
dress again everybody miles says look at me
freaking Mona Lisa what is about to go down
on your feet genius I want to see your Duke
oh no no not him not my dude
[Music]
oh why him who gave him that drink they were
pre-prepared you're not saying it was done
with intention are you well we don't know
my guess is something was put in his drink
yeah guys obviously what if this was the elaborate
plan the whole time from Eddie Norden when
we will convene here and walk together to
the dock I'll stay up all night but the body
make sure it's not tampered with it anyway
I reckon it's meant for me was meant for him
yeah oh
he picked up mine foreign
I'll pay you one billion dollars to tell me
which one of them tried to kill me do it make
that make the bag
this phone look oh the gun my murder game
we were gonna be having drinks and I thought
it'd be fun to say something dramatic just
at 10 o'clock and then we're gonna have 20
minutes where help me what happens at 10 o'clock
what this beer God oh not today
this can't be any it's just too off it'd be
too obvious but what if that's a subversion
of expectations and I plunk did it listen
did you take Duke's gun I'm gonna take Duke's
gun and why are the lights dude what it's
a great Motif with the lighthouse oh cool
that's this Ethan Hawke I don't know Kate
Hudson we only need one last piece of information
but only you can do it
maybe miles is doing it and is trying to kill
them all [Music] no this is like a tragedy
she can't be dead only one person can tell
us who killed Cassandra brand 10 years ago
you crap is this Benoit blocks residency [Music]
is someone here for you with a box
foreign [Laughter] oh interesting my name
is Helen brand two days ago I received a call
my twin sister committed huh fascinating my
sister was Cassandra brand and I'm just thinking
about what was taken from my sister and I'm
getting angrier and angrier and then I just
hear her knock at the door and it's some carrier
with this thing from Miles Braun shot sent
this at 4 pm the day she was murdered four
days ago I finally found it it's right here
and I'm going to use it to burn his whole
empire no you know where to find me hey that
which can be destroyed by the truth I searched
every inch of every room in her house and
guess what wasn't there the Red Envelope damn
it's like clue oh my God he's putting up an
act this whole time you come with me to that
Island as your sister Sandra brand is that
why miles was so surprised to see her oh maybe
one of those [__] killed my she's great
yeah it's miles hey nice to meet you bro hey
first nobody liked him he wants to create
something that feels lasting that feels this
first Venture was movie phoned for foot massages
did it work no he got birdie a show for our
designs it did well got Lyle published Duke
set up at twitch Claire elected locally back
you know small stuff but it happened building
a cult the thing happened what is that you're
working on
no Andy Andy come on this is it it's just
exactly like Steve Jobs
subtlety miles had the lawyers work the contract
so she was cut out the company completely
so she sued over there her whole case was
based on intellectual ownership of the company's
founding idea her idea on the napkin which
she didn't keep oh God damn he had an idea
uh so he grabbed an apple and he [__]
locked me in the eye Claire you know it's
a lie it's a lie and do you recall Mr Cody
oh you all deserve to die right after the
verdict miles suddenly found them handwriting
and did all those interviews about it bold
face fabrication a damn lie tomato tomato
true no way oh is that what was in the envelope
it's the original motive opportunity hey this
kind of looks like that yes I love them together
I know he's always got to get paired up with
a young scared but strong woman
it's the major Trope of the knives out Universe
then we're all settling in bro's gonna pull
me aside to explain my presence that is your
chance to snoop snoop Snoop
nope this is brilliantly done yeah God damn
I'm loving this it's completely recontextualized
in the first hour that's so smart I don't
really like wow what the hell re-watch this
would be yeah all the different Clues tells
I know I sold my soul for this you're telling
me that it literally turned people's homes
into the hinden park cool hidden homes there
was a time you know back when
moment
I thought you said you didn't drink that's
hard kombucha that's Jared Leto's heart kombucha
you need to stop because as it turns out nobody
wants you to break ah [__] she was drunk
can we talk about the email you did even write
back that's why I called when we couldn't
reach you I went to your house Lionel and
I got there at the same time oh my God they'll
do it together
probably you were already there he almost
got in an accident on his motorcycle he was
driving so fast okay okay can you say all
that one more time for me please
okay but none of them fessed up to haven't
had a conversation yep and they would have
had to have snuck something in her drink it's
a great use of the suspicions from earlier
too everyone's like she's not quite right
this case confounds me it just confounds oh
we don't have a motive for Duke or birdie
do either of you two want to do a session
or what oh my God it's live Lionel Lionel
faction hold on it doesn't necessarily mean
you know well right now go to him we really
need to do this for me one last time okay
oh he
stuck her on him ew oh ah no wonder it wasn't
like yeah okay oh is this twisted [Music]
clever an email from the sweetypants contractor
two years ago inviting to inform you that
the proposed Bangladesh factories notoriously
one of the world's biggest sweatshops please
advise sounds perfect thanks oh oh you great
[Laughter] [__] please tell me you did
not
are where they sweaters sweatpants oh geez
you said if I take full responsibility for
the sweatshops he'll pay me the value of my
shares 30 million I have my secret no
whoever killed your sister took that envelope
to protect miles they wouldn't just destroy
it that would want him to see what they'd
done for him they brought it here they'll
have to hide it in their room with dinner
tonight smart yeah we have to find that envelope
you're the loser that's the truth there it
is there it is
[Music] woof [Music]
hey Daryl damn it
[Music]
okay oh no oh no it has broken ah
oh no oh no no no no he didn't deserve this
he deserved what he would and you are better
off with that
[Music] what the [__] oh damn don't kill
me oh my God I'm not trying to kill you you
crazy [__] please
God who's the killer this is really hard yeah
it's in the glass you know if I can distract
everyone and you can get up there and find
it no but that doesn't tell us who gave it
to him we only need one last piece of information
but only you can do it [Music] even though
you can see it coming okay but still [Music]
what play dead
protected you from Beyond the Grave uh that's
why I said leave her body
foreign
[Music]
and I was nice what right at the center
so it was just miles I guess what it teased
my brain through this entire case in abbreviate
yeah I thought that earlier fully abbreviate
this moment
it's wonderful is a disaster his grasp of
disruption theory is remedial of best [Laughter]
nobody tried to kill you your vain glorious
buffoon Duke took my glass that's what you
told us he did
he did what did we all actually see wow look
at that dress bin Bertie that's amazing just
just you hand it too nice when Duke got to
Andy's house early on his motorcycle
[Music]
was almost struck by him damn you remember
that night you almost pancake me with it on
the road outside of Anderson Cooper's birthday
[Music] focus on the envelope foreign
threat until it was too late
but he didn't know Andy was dead no no he
didn't know that until this evening when he
got a Google alert on his phone which is which
is Fallen strangely silent which he showed
to you
right out in the open Duke showed him the
changes things right sure does maybe we can
talk Alpha news bet your ass come here what
are the ingredients you all Cuban Breeze a
vodka Amaretto oh God
is he allergic to almonds [Music] no pineapple
now right oh pineapple yeah he just put pineapple
juice in his whisket it's so dumb it's a clue
you have a loaded gun conveniently Within
Reach it's like putting a loaded gun on the
table and turning off the light uh door one
murder with any
bullet idea from me Jesus so it was ever fired
it and then you be capable of making the shot
he's got a good aim at least how could you
ever prove that that's the original she might
have copied mine the bar closed nine years
ago and hers has one thing to choose
ah yeah I just noticed that too yeah okay
but second
[Music] oh oh you [__] well did you see
just proof this smoking napkin Blanc did anybody
oh [__] you [__] you [__] everybody
seems to have very foggy recollection of what
they actually saw and there's nothing but
totally circumspective evidence so if
your sister was a complicated woman but she
meant the world to me
raise your hand and say
and say I saw him that night at Andy's house
y'all suck on his Tate golden teat I have
to answer to the police the courts the system
there's nothing I can do oh that's heartbreaking
except maybe
offer you some courage and a reminder of why
your sister walked away in the first place
is there something I'm missing [Music]
laughs [Music] Chuck she's good when she drinks
chug [Music] wreck the Mona Lisa [Music] wanted
them a nugget of fear hell yeah hell yeah
foreign
yes
turn the room
okay
[Music] this must have been a fun day on set
I think that belonged to Liberace okay are
we done
go for Mona what
what is it what do you want
ah
we're not oh God whoa so play is gonna explode
it all down walk away with a reminder of why
my sister walked away in the first place oh
[Music]
reduce it to Ash
oh [__]
[Music]
less Garden
disruption
[Music]
those cars wrecked the whole empire
come on
yep yep
[Music]
that's awesome
beautiful no like [Laughter]
oh yep
what you've done watch that expression oh
God it's all Core built off of that oh your
feel of the future just barbecued the world's
most famous painting you dumbass and now you'll
be mentioned in the same sentence forever
yeah exactly and you did get your wish
or be remembered
[Music] we know what happened I saw the napkin
he burned
I clearly saw him grab Duke's gun I saw him
driving away from Andy's house the night she
was killed
you ready to go home
yeah and the next movie he'll be paired up
with an Asian girl that's right
[Music]
well done dope
all right
he ruined the first Knives Out ah they woke
it
that was great yeah that was a lot of fun
it was solid that Ryan Johnson just loves
those subversions
smart because it seems so obvious that it
would be ever Norton yeah but I was like I
actually did the thing that I said look it's
too obvious so you can't suspect him yeah
I notice him but the movie threw me for a
loop when because it did seem like someone
was targeting him yeah did a good job at that
oh because I didn't I didn't really suspect
anyone else other than like so I was like
okay if it might be Andy but then uh when
she was dead it was like I don't really suspect
anyone else yeah it's like none of them have
enough reason to kill her yeah but then I
don't know they kept throwing you for a loop
it's like the first prediction that's kind
of the first movie kind of does that yeah
her sevens were like might be Chris Evans
and then it steers you off that road yeah
totally and then you're like oh no it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah the misdirect but no you should
stick with your gut instead all along yeah
anyhow I mean you're you're designed to sit
there and go like okay well maybe there's
some kind of hidden detail that we don't know
yet about all these different characters but
all right we'll shitty chatter put on my neck
scarf doesn't match this outfit but I brought
it for just this occasion perfect Benoit Blanc
scarf perfect yeah well well well well um
I liked it quite a bit I liked it a lot I
enjoyed it a lot um that was fun it's a fun
game to play along with absolutely yeah and
uh I really did you it's coming off of knives
out you know like I'm not here to do a comparison
thing but coming off of knives out after having
that fresh in your mind because I saw it that
one time in the theaters which I thought was
a magical like I thought the first if there's
one like off the cuff uh comparison I'd make
it because like structurally they're very
different obviously and I actually love that
because you don't need to watch the first
one yeah at all yeah like you really don't
need to watch the first one whatsoever to
to like to appreciate this film or understand
it or follow it or even like it you know um
so I do think that it makes for a great complimentary
piece because of the fact of how different
it is I think you might appreciate aspects
of it more if you watch the first one but
I love that you don't need to watch it whatsoever
uh there's a there's like a rare kind of sequel
to make yeah absolutely I mean coming off
of Knives Out fresh in your mind what'd you
think fresh in my mind I thought this was
yeah a terrific way of building on that and
looking back at the original movie like it's
still held up for my viewing experience there
are a couple times where I feel like it maybe
thinks it's a little bit more Grand than it
actually is but I think here they managed
to kind of take that Grandeur and Infuse it
even even more like the first movie is is
great because of its restraint and because
of how it's playing on a more austere version
of the genre and this version is is like we
were saying you know is going into a more
broad more swashbuckling more sort of you
know James Bond scope and I appreciated that
and I appreciated how this played off of like
in the first movie Benoit Blanc is like he
has such a Mystique and he's so cool uh for
so much of it and you know even the way they
introduce him he's like always in the background
just observing and then he slowly implements
himself into the plot and here I thought they
played off of that really well and just in
these few moments since the movie The more
I've thought about it just the more it feels
like it took the ball from the first movie
and the way it wanted to subvert those expectations
and I feel like there's something about the
first movie where I can imagine certain people
being like wait wait wait the subversion ah
you know like is it truly fully satisfying
I think here uh he managed to layer multiples
on top of that have multiple kind of games
going at once and so yeah I thought it was
a fantastic way to build on it to take the
personality of the first movie but also do
its very own thing this time and yeah having
that one connective tissue of Ben Wa Blanc
and giving him just enough like extra character
here to flesh him out as a continuing character
if you do want to pay attention to it establish
is gay he's gay he's gay I mean they brought
up donut holes that's true the first one was
a clear metaphor and the donut hole in the
donut and the donut little donut yeah which
was the first indication so it shouldn't come
as too big of a surprise no um but I mean
that wasn't just his Butler I I did I yeah
I thought this was fine I think the you know
the first movie left me with a feeling of
of a lot of awe and I was like I was in love
with that one and I thought it was really
intense too sure and so this this leaves you
with a different feeling and I and I feel
like the the first obvious feeling I had with
this one is oh this would make for one hell
of a re-watch sure yes which I didn't quite
get I imagine Knives Out is a great re-watch
I haven't done it but but because of the way
this movie is structured where it does set
it up of okay they're doing like a a different
they're doing a sequel they're doing a part
two where instead of you know Benoit Blanc
being a uh super badass who's who's uh brought
onto this case and everything and it has this
mystery surrounding him he's you know kind
of in the slumps here the pandemic and the
mentality is really affecting him and he feels
like a stranger caught off guard and uh he
looks like the odd man out out of this group
of everyone who really knows him he he seems
like the least knowledgeable one fish out
of water it will be the quality here you know
and I and then to find out that oh he's not
yeah he's been very much in control this whole
time that's what I mean by the flip Roo like
I thought it was really cool how they really
at the middle of this movie they literally
go over the first hour yeah and you see it
from the perspectives of Helen and Bena Blanc
um Benoit Blanc from his uh actual real involvement
I thought was really that was cleverly done
yeah and it made me go I want to re-watch
this just because of that because like the
last movie has an immediate kickoff death
point right and and then games afoot we're
here you're like okay something's happen something's
going to happen yeah yeah something hasn't
happened what is the game exactly and because
of the fact that you know it's got to be a
big murder mystery due to they're setting
up that stage for it obviously with the with
the game and uh but also being the fact that
it is a part two you know like there's something
coming so you have that built-in faith that
something's about to happen but you're waiting
a while you're in like 45 minutes before something
for that real plot actually takes off and
kicks into high gear you know and uh and you're
spending time with all these characters and
learning A Whole New World and and the the
world that they're setting in is very like
what I call like social media topical yeah
totally everything every character represents
a faction of the now part of the yeah faction
of the the current conversation especially
from the pandemic yeah and on like it doesn't
go fully you know into it's political commentary
oh [__] it's like a thousand persons cultural
commentary at least yeah yeah yeah no a thousand
percent um you even have the Edward Norton
character as a as a play on the billionaires
who don't really know anything but they know
how to take advantage and use people and take
all the credit yeah you know and I mean to
see Edward Norton like I appreciate that he
is so down for roles like that because it
is a very unflattering character that he plays
very well yeah a good sleazeball yeah uh I
I enjoyed I enjoyed that uh quality quite
a bit and the kit the characters are I think
every actor here is really solid I think everyone's
great um yeah I mean totally I do love the
flipper that they do boy the um Blanc in this
movie because you you don't even see that
reveal really coming yeah but there are those
hints of it especially with the fact that
he doesn't seem suspect at all about like
if you look at the first half of this movie
he doesn't seem suspect that much suspect
about Andy yeah even when she's gone missing
and and Bautista's dead I mean he just goes
up to her and talks to her yeah you know okay
interesting choice yeah oh no this makes makes
a lot of sense I mean similar to how anode
armis was the scene stealer of that film uh
it's like Janelle Monae in this movie is is
that Replay that supplement yeah which is
very it's very I think that's the most like
obvious comparison too is like you should
pair them off and then you have Janelle Monae
who's kind of like the odd one out yeah totally
you have these and people who have been wronged
by the circumstances and the systems put in
place by the very environment that they're
in who he's eventually going to basically
Empower to take back you know what uh has
been slighted them by all these messed up
circumstances I do remember the first movie
coming out around Thanksgiving which felt
appropriate because it was a play on dysfunctional
family yeah and the big family gathering where
this is like Caribbean Vibes yeah yeah coming
out of Christmas beautiful sandy beaches and
whatnot yeah I mean it is an interesting contrast
and hey I mean maybe it'll be a nice break
from the cold for people yeah but I do think
some of the I do think some of the sometimes
comment certain kinds of commentary can feel
extremely on the nose in this movie and then
some of the more like celebrity call out names
and stuff like that yeah I mean if it's the
environment in the world but it brings it
kind I want to say it pulls me out however
it does make me aware even more so of the
screenplay sure the screenplay is a character
yeah when you do [__] like that yeah because
this movie is like filled with it you know
it is yeah in the first movie is much more
insulated to its own universe and I'm I'm
still kind of chewing on how I feel about
that because I think there's certain aspects
of this one that coalesce a little bit better
even for me because like the cast in the first
movie is great um and there are times where
I feel like they just kind of Revel in that
a bit where at in certain moments it would
take me out of the overall of the situation
go oh man whoever I'm looking at right now
is having a lot of fun or something like that
whereas here I thought like they really coalesced
all together and it wasn't just this amazing
cast of people but I really believed the kind
of whole unit of their different friendships
and their overlapping motivations and whatnot
in a way that felt a bit more Earnest in a
sense and a bit more a bit less self-aware
at least from how it was all played out through
the acting I think it's clever of how he met
with a complimentary piece again now the first
movie's uh oh it's a family but they're not
a real loving family and this is a friend
group and they've been best friends forever
but they're not a real friend group yeah yeah
yeah it's all conniving underneath yeah and
everyone had a great personality and I think
the way they they when especially when you
flip the movie halfway through when it is
okay not who would kill miles but who would
kill Andy when you get to the both but especially
with Andy not I like I think with Miles and
you're like okay maybe this person maybe this
room when it came to the time with Andy you're
like well any one of them could have done
it yeah any one of them has a motive now yeah
to to kill them yeah let's kill Andy and I
love that too though like the way I feel like
part of the knives out franchise you know
formula now has to be that the central murder
or whatever is a subversion of some kind and
I thought here they did a really satisfying
job of that because it's like he says yeah
you brought everybody here you planted the
idea of your own murder in everyone's head
with the audience as well and then yeah you
have this uh prior murder that is much like
I think the more I've thought about it because
there is a certain element of like oh it's
just it's just him he's the most likely per
it would have to be him in a way uh but at
the same time I thought that fit the theme
really well and everybody is a layer on the
Glass Onion but he is the center of it you
know he is you know the core that they're
all trying to cling to for fear of being peeled
away well what I would say about even even
though you know it was like he would be the
obvious suspect because the movie tries throwing
you off of that scent and I bought into the
scent I took the bait yeah basically is what
I did yeah especially with you know there's
even a line at one point where uh Helen does
say something about what about miles and he
says hi it would be that dumb or yeah yeah
and then coming down to how dumb he actually
is using that need that sort of uh uh you
know like chronic need to yes take ideas and
reappropriate them and then claim them as
your own like it's it's it's woven again like
in the moment you could be like oh really
it's just him but then the amount of detail
it laces in to support that and I love that
little thing about all the misnomer words
that he's throwing out because it's one of
those details that in the moment you catch
but then you don't have enough time you know
to kind of be like wait a minute is that a
real word though it's like kind of go off
on that tangent and yeah like I thought it
was really tightly wound on those details
and the amount of those details that were
given to every character or even a character
like whiskey there was way more to than and
you would expect whereas like and again let's
just keep on comparing but you have like certain
Side characters in the first film that are
just kind of there and don't get much flesh
whereas here keeping it a little more contained
to a smaller slightly smaller group I think
enabled them to really Heap the richness onto
most everybody say for maybe Jessica henwick
but you know even her presence I still appreciate
it overall well what was cool about this it
wasn't until um when when uh Blanc dismantles
the whole murder mystery game that Edward
Norton has set forth yeah because it is just
like such an ensemble movie where it doesn't
even feel like a Knives Out sequel yeah and
it doesn't even feel like blonk's movie or
Adventure yeah he's on because you're just
waiting for the the thing to kick off and
then when the glasses pull I mean the curtains
pulled back then you find out oh you've been
watching kind of blanc's game this whole time
yeah and I think that's really clever too
like no this is still his movie yeah he's
not only is the killer steps ahead but so
is he already before we're even aware but
even with the Edward Norton ultimate reveal
what I what I didn't catch was the even though
he was a prime suspect number one and would
be the most likely one and was the most obvious
pick it the when they did do the cutaways
to show like this was shown to you in the
movie already that he what that he is the
one who did it yeah when they're doing those
cutaways that Ryan Johnson puts in the edit
I didn't catch that just based purely off
of motive and stuff was the one but all those
things like with the thing with the glass
switching and uh taking the gun yeah all those
things are like okay yeah yeah that that is
clever it is it's it is a it's still a very
like clever film and I I really I didn't I
didn't like it a lot I wouldn't say I loved
it though there was something about that that's
been the only thing I've been trying to sort
of figure out of what what is the thing that's
kind of holding me back from saying I I love
this film because I would actually agree with
you when it comes to that about the characters
but I think I still actually enjoyed the Ensemble
more and it's not even just off comparison
like I said it's been a few years since I've
seen knives out and I saw it one time so it's
not like I have this High reverence before
Knives Out to the point where I'm like I'm
just gonna be watching this comparing it it's
more remembering the feeling that the last
one left me with and that one I I think uh
something maybe it might have just been because
it was family Dynamic that I'm just more drawn
to naturally of a dysfunctional family that
I I think is a easier emotional click to it
uh but the characters here while I enjoyed
everyone I I didn't I wouldn't say I I loved
watching most of them like no one was really
quite uh Edward Norman kind of comes like
kind of known was really quite a Chris Evans
to me to get deliciously despicable or something
like that and I feel and it's interesting
because there are things about that in the
first movie that maybe take me out of the
coalescence of things but it's not there's
no denying yeah that he is Chris Evans for
example in that movie among many other characters
is delightful to watch and especially to watch
him have so much fun being such a dastardly
character even though uh yeah like you know
the ultimate core of where that's going and
here I feel like this movie has a much more
like the first movie is a more classic sensibility
is a bit more analog sensibility and so you're
kind of again contained within its world and
it's while there are certain nods to you know
just current life there's not a lot of that
whereas here this is very very of the now
and the characters are despicable in a more
modern kind of way in that a lot of them are
very vapid and spineless and and yeah even
though they're all kind of interesting in
their own way because of what the actors bring
to them um I don't know yeah there's there's
maybe something a little less colorful or
or truly unique about them like they all feel
like they kind of came from the same set whereas
it Knives Out the first one you have kind
of do you have different Generations you have
different you know modes of this wealth Empire
you know different uh leverages in that sense
whereas everybody here is kind of under the
same circumstance well it felt like a a Hollywood
movie pair up of archetypes yeah in this friend
group you know sure yeah because the friend
like okay this person's running for Senate
that's the governor character yeah this person's
the chemist yeah this person is the influencer
you know and uh there so there was it was
that thing where there I was very I guess
this time around this movie just made me so
much more aware that I was more impressed
structurally with the film like I was never
quite I didn't find it suspenseful I didn't
find it like intense it was always fun and
and it is cathartic yeah and it was fun to
play with it was fun to play along with the
movie you know to to me to sort of try to
figure it out and and see what the ultimate
reveal is and I think Janelle Monae is phenomenal
oh yeah so I think she's phenomenal in this
like her and Daniel Craig are awesome in here
yeah um but yeah this this was more uh of
a more structurally impressive experience
to me than anything else yeah I feel like
the writing and directing are like the main
star and then everybody else is a supporting
character of The Ensemble yeah yeah they're
filming that all in yeah and so and and I
appreciate that in the sense that you can
take these as to very unique experiences unto
themselves and I can imagine various people
having wildly different opinions about which
one they like more but I do appreciate that
the core of both movies is Blanc and whoever
is the sort of good-hearted person in the
middle of all these despicable other characters
trying to you know gain some kind of reclamation
or do the right thing and I think that this
nails that certainly and yeah it's I'm interested
to see how the following day is kind of ensue
it when where this movie settles for me because
on the surface the first movie has slightly
more things that just for me personally as
a viewer maybe take me out or maybe feel like
okay you're not quite quite as like god tier
right now as you as you seem to kind of be
playing it as you are but at the same time
looking at this that like they were on the
surface so many things that felt kind of so
tight and that at least in an experiential
way smoothed out those gripes I would have
had and yet yeah I still kind of wonder if
the first one would still be my favorite just
because of the things that so much of it does
coalesce in a way that truly does feel distinct
and all the characters do feel kind of completely
of their own thing rather than cut of a similar
cloth and kind of riffing variations on the
same sort of set of people um I don't know
either way like they're both really satisfying
and I appreciate the way that Ryan Johnson
is able to pay tribute to a classic genre
and also bring a lot of new and interesting
sensibility to it and the first one gives
you that package of like an Agatha Christie
type of movie and this one gives you a package
of something much more modern but I I still
think that they managed to kind of Eek A Classic
quality out of it sure yeah I haven't seen
death on a knob but this feels like we're
death on a Nile might be and I've heard that
too it's like never death on the Niles like
it's been more fun it's about where wild the
mystery isn't quite as hard to crack but still
like there's a lot of great work you know
yeah there's some good there's some good unveils
all around and I think for um I think for
Janelle Monae I think that was a just she
had to play both characters and I thought
she did an Exquisite job on both yeah and
it's a it is a again it's like a it would
I never doubt it this is the first thing I
never doubt it's another really well shot
film and Incredibly incredibly edited oh yeah
on top of all that it's like clockwork this
yeah yeah no no it is like a it's like watching
a surgeon go to work yeah yeah and it's got
enough sort of Quirk and esoterica that it's
just like kind of engrossing on its own for
how outlandish it is and it doesn't feel too
outlandish for how colorful a lot of the things
are I don't understand Ethan Hawke being here
I like I think the Hue Grant Cameo is way
more of a of a well utilized celebrity Cameo
sure even though it's less of a screen time
um the fact that he is like a character who
plays a an emotional purposeful part to uh
Blanc works and to get was he doing a Southern
accent or is he just British I couldn't tell
what I was like am I not hearing who Grant's
voice properly it's been a while yeah yeah
I thought I I thought he was just Hugh Grant
but I would have to go back and look at it
it's still fun to have him there I think Ethan
Hawke was like I'm so aware I'm watching Ethan
Hawk that felt like is just here to be Ethan
Hawke's doing what Ethan Hawk would do with
this for a couple minutes that very much felt
like one of those things where it's like oh
I would love to be in oh yeah I just come
down for a day you know I've got a part for
you sure like jump in yeah and like it's fun
but yeah it doesn't it doesn't feel as clever
as something like Hugh Grant because Hugh
Grant you hear his voice and you get that
satisfaction being like Oh that's who that
was it's like he was here the whole time but
did the pandemic I I thought it was interesting
they set this during the pandemic did it is
there something I'm missing did it quite I
thought it would have more of a factor I guess
yeah like they're they're it's brought up
tangentially but it just seemed like kind
of an interesting opportunity I guess to to
use the here and now as an excuse to get them
in an isolated location like it doesn't seem
incredibly purposeful because you know it's
like the thing he's working on is off that
way yeah yeah I mean it feels like yeah it's
a very distinct part of the movie and I and
I like that you have that at least affecting
Blanc in a way where he's like it seems like
he's cooped up and partly is just there's
not a case right now but it seems like I don't
know maybe there's no murder happening yeah
there's less big old murder cases happening
around him or whatever um but yeah it's not
like Edward Norton's working on some kind
of biopharmaceutical thing you know he like
that could have factored in it could have
been a 2022 movie it could be a 20. it could
be any time yeah yeah yeah yeah so I feel
like that was just them kind of using their
surroundings or or something well it wasn't
even really just the pandemic it was really
they utilized like 20 20. yeah you know yeah
I mean because yeah like they are that's what
every one of these people is kind of a commentary
on yeah it's a very 2020s kind of situation
that's the core of all this we are at the
time of disruptors and all these people who
are like pseudo influencer business slash
political figures well it doesn't go sci-fi
but there are there are some semis if I quite
like the whole thing with the hydrogen explosion
thingy of uh clear yeah um like that's a an
invention that's a Bond movie yeah it's a
Bond movie that's all the setting it's kind
of a bond yeah this takes place at like the
evil masterminds headquarters except he's
really dumb and bond doesn't need gadgets
he just needs his intellect yeah like in some
ways this does feel like the audition tape
for Ryan Johnson's uh James Bond movie or
something like that because that's like even
though there are again like we said more classic
kind of romanticized swashbuckling Vibes and
there's certainly the requisite Agatha Christie
sort of murder mystery Vibes the most I got
the most overt tone I got was like a James
Bond thing like this all felt very James Bondi
just with a different Dynamic of how to solve
the case you know yeah and what that means
it's it's a it feels a little more light-hearted
to me a little quirkier and yeah somehow felt
smaller somehow felt more contained yeah even
though you're on this luxurious billionaire
Island and and the cast is bigger I think
being able to leave the house in the first
movie helped because you're like the car chase
yeah yeah because you get at least a couple
moments to remember there are other people
just out in the world you know you're not
just yeah it's not like it almost feels like
in a way using the pandemic Clues you into
the fact that yeah they probably had to keep
this as spare as possible so how do we know
that's true how do we shoot without extras
and needing to have crowds of any kind the
pandemic Vibe kind of looms throughout sure
so I think I think the backdrop of the pandemic
helps if anything it serves more of a backdrop
than it does as a actual character in the
film yeah it doesn't seem like a real point
of emphasis for any particular subtext or
any sort of aspect or facet of the mystery
at large they gotta ring among us into it
yeah there you go well there you go here it
is it's the panda yeah it's the pandemic of
uh of of you know of spinelessness and uh
deceit you know it's like all of them are
infected by the need to protect this guy and
then they are cured with the vaccine of Truth
and then eventually they fight back I wanted
them [__] I wanted them all to get their
comeuppance though because they're all horrible
I don't like any of these people like I don't
like any of them they're all horrible people
yeah and there's something because it's like
it's weird because the first movie they're
mostly all horrible people too but there are
but they don't want what do they want I want
the will or some [__] is that yeah they're
all they're all back biting and then fighting
on the will but they still leave you it's
like even though Jamie Lee Curtis for example
is a hard ass there's still something Charming
about her at the end or the daughter in that
movie I think her name is Meg uh she's like
she is a pretty sympathetic character in general
or you have the grandma who would again is
a total character doesn't speak really but
is somewhat sympathetic whereas here yeah
like I don't know Leslie Odom Jr seems kind
of okay despite the fact that he too is you
know aboard this train and actively putting
people in danger so yeah it seems like the
only good people really at all are Benoit
and and Helen and and yeah so that adds a
certain I guess maybe one I won't say one
dimensionality but it takes an element of
Dimension uh from most of like the only other
likable characters whiskey is and I like that
like I like that the movie is is sort of uh
compassionate I guess I'll say enough to be
like here's a character who you know these
movies are designed for you to make judgments
and associations and you know think of what
you're presented with and I liked here that
they peeled back those layers and made her
an actual character and and she's pretty likable
and you feel for the position she's in from
like the one brief scene you get of her but
yeah everybody else is pretty much like oh
you guys all made this bed and you even though
now you're kind of coming around to the truth
and coming around to you know standing up
to this guy it literally took all this you
know and somebody else again doing all the
work for you well I didn't think too that
they because I set up everyone's like you
know they all met with the Glass Onion um
ages ago right at that bar or they didn't
meet there but that was their thing and and
then it's all these years later and they're
setting up their backstories and the journeys
they've been on and and whatever and I thought
that I guess this was sort of an expectation
that I thought the movie set up for me that
all that would have this like Collision or
I'll coalesce together in some way but it
sort of just seemed like uh Dave Bautista's
dead and who's trying to kill Andy like he's
kind of just stopped in the in the middle
of the tracks and I like the direction it
went because what I what was cool structurally
about this film was it's because it's setting
all that up and it's leading to the murder
mystery game and then I was like all right
so what they're doing is they're setting up
everyone's backstory so odds are what's gonna
happen is miles is probably going to really
die at this murder mystery and who's the one
who really killed him and we've established
everyone's backstory so which so he's you
think it's going to go down that route right
at least that's what the movie's setting up
to me yeah is that it's going down that route
of miles is really gonna die at this thing
and then but Block's gonna have to do his
thing and investigate everyone's backstory
yeah some more and then try to find out who's
the one who really killed miles but then it
doesn't do that yeah you know that's the biggest
subversion of the expectation because you're
like 45 minutes in uh Blanc just uproots the
whole thing you know blows the whole game
and it becomes a completely different direction
uh for the film I still found myself craving
because and I think that's why I wanted like
the comeuppance or some [__] you know
it's kind of just like it adds layers and
it makes makes the characters characters more
than just you know someone like Kate Hudson
could have just easily been just that one
note thing that she is you know like you're
just so dumb I don't even I don't even know
how you got this far like this Miss films
didn't have a commentary of like rich people
and people in power are actual idiots and
that that's like a main takeaway for a lot
of these people they're all dumb you know
um uh except for they didn't really do that
with Catherine Hahn um no but they don't also
really give her no yeah so I mean I thought
that some of their because they spent especially
with Edward given that great speech about
like everything they did that I thought that
would all somehow some of that would come
to the surface a little bit more it could
have been a way too packed of a film if they
did that yeah for sure but there is a but
the first one even does have a bit of resolve
for many of the personal squabbles that were
happening outside of the main murder mystery
whereas this one there isn't really much of
that like you know you don't you don't really
know what awaits any of them other than maybe
they'll be better people now this is miles
is the center of it but they're all they're
all they're terrible they were all terrible
yeah complicit in all this terrible stuff
the second they show the courtroom scene with
Andy I'm like oh you guys suck I don't want
any of you guys to come out of this alive
I hope you all die yeah well and part of me
it's weird part of me thought they were going
yeah the sister was gonna make this crazy
sacrifice and I was like I don't know exactly
how I would feel about Blanc for for you know
condoning that or pushing that but at the
same time it did feel like that would be a
very bold statement for the movie to make
it while I do like and appreciate that the
point is you know it's not enough to have
the evidence because so much of the time in
real life crime and cases you have that problem
of there's just not enough evidence to present
even though we all know the truth but yeah
yeah so they've all got to come around but
but yeah that's more of a function which is
again a very like 20 20ish sure thing to oh
yeah so that became very topical yeah yeah
and like I like that as a theme I think it
works well for the the place and the setting
but it's a macro theme more than it is like
a personal character related theme and this
I don't think does quite as much to have both
whereas the previous movie does a little bit
more of that it's like it's weird it's like
the first Knives Out in the immediate moment
gave me slightly more thing things to be like
a little not suspect of but I had like slightly
more little nitpicks and gripes along the
way but the longer term impact I think is
a bit greater whereas this one like in the
moment I was eating it up and I and I would
love to watch it again like I I really liked
it I think the lasting impact will be a little
bit less yeah than the original movie but
yeah it's like it's still really tightly wound
and it's still really well conceived for the
most part I've thought I might be and I could
be wrong here um because this movie did actually
really well in its limited release in the
theaters and it's got a great response so
far and I imagine almost any movie is better
in the theaters all right regardless of course
this movie is is more than likely odds of
it being better in the theaters extremely
high you know uh and uh so I I understand
that sentiment but the movie did not leave
me with a feeling of I I wish I had seen this
in the theaters or uh this would have been
better like even if I was at home alone with
the lights off I'm like yeah that's fine watching
this yeah Netflix yeah yeah I'm not but I
I wasn't thinking about it even yeah yeah
I mean I'd be happy to see the theaters but
it was yeah but I'm not I'm not ditching or
I'm Not Really Gonna carve out time like that's
the one way to see it yeah yeah I don't I
don't have that urge it's like I saw everything
everywhere all at once I mean Grant a very
different kind of film and it's very like
cinematic visual feast and all that um but
I like I reacted to that here and then five
days later I want to watch in the theaters
would be so because that that leaves me with
that feeling and and knives out to me was
such a Grand Theater experience yeah yeah
yeah and um so again I don't know if I if
I will maybe maybe if I re-watch knives out
at home I'll be like oh you know maybe not
as strong as I thought it was because it's
hot at home um but yeah this this this wasn't
as to me this this did kind of lack an excitement
factor I didn't find it quite exciting I was
always intrigued and I was I was having fun
but I wouldn't say this was exciting I think
that's a good distinction to make is the difference
between yeah fun versus exciting and like
even though this has a more overtly exciting
package like yeah you you do miss a certain
amount of tension you're always wondering
you're always asking you're always engrossed
but it doesn't necessarily feel like anyone
could die at any moment or something like
that or or you know that like there's I don't
know like if it seems like it should feel
more uh like more intense because you have
the murderer lurking in your midst and at
one point you have that classic glove shot
and everything like that and it yeah it doesn't
it Quicken your heart rate or make you go
like oh man you know is block gonna die you
know what are they gonna try and kill Blanc
you know yeah it's a bit more like okay but
we gotta keep going we gotta keep getting
these more details you know yeah well I think
it's really focused on doing its mid point
reveal yes yeah but but and and to be fair
I guess like even the first movie had this
effect on me whereas like the the most engrossing
and the most sort of endearing thing is that
Central Duo of Blanc and whoever he's helping
right now and there were moments where those
pulled me in enough that I forgot about like
when I thought she was just dead I like I
completely forgot about that because of how
great those scenes worked and I think that
is a true credit and that does add at least
some element of that tension but yeah it's
not as prevalent throughout and and for as
much as these bits and pieces are overlapping
they're much more self-serving than they feel
outwardly threatening well I mean I I think
the only person you kind of care about is
block where you're only periodically checking
in with in the first half of this movie and
then and then the person you become really
emotionally attuned to or or connected with
as an audience member would be uh the Helen
character right yeah because like at least
on my end I wasn't like we're barely spending
time with Andy and I'm only hearing like you
know some information being dished out yeah
so I don't I'm not really latched on to it
in an emotional way until you you get the
reveal of Helen and all that stuff which comes
like almost an hour into the film yeah and
like I said I'm only using knives out as an
example right now to say like what what what
worked for me there was you do get really
hooked into honor Day armis on an emotional
way yeah very early on yes you do like it's
it's one of the she's like the main character
of that film and and they they set that up
yeah you're like oh halfway through you're
like oh cheese to me here yeah yeah interesting
cool subversion but also we're yeah we're
in and that's what I meant by um structurally
it's it's a very a really admire that's on
a structural experience like it's really unique
in that way but wasn't they didn't have that
main character where I was and I think without
having that main character that limits me
from feeling that excitement or that or that
intensity yeah and then even with the whole
thing of because because even I was watching
I was like oh but she's gonna die oh she's
not dead okay cool they're kind of felt like
it wrapped up pretty fast yeah it's like go
up there we didn't think about that like oh
oh that thing you've flat out said early on
to ignore yeah yeah yeah and and there's also
I feel like they almost bridged the Gap with
having Blanc be such a fish out of water in
the first half because he does kind of take
on this slight main character quality because
you do get a little bit of a personal look
into his life at least that he doesn't know
what to do he is and his codery of very notable
friends you know uh trying to fill the hours
between cases and then having him come to
this party and be so kind of charmingly out
of place yeah I thought they were doing the
thing where oh it's blanc's gonna have the
ark yeah and it's like okay the first movie
he's such a figure he's such a mystery and
he makes you feel safe because he's here and
he's in control and now oh it's the complete
opposite but then halfway through we go back
to oh no no he's in control and we're safe
yeah yeah and he is the Blanc I always knew
and expected he would be I just know that
at home he's a little more disheveled because
they they set you up like oh belongs off his
game yeah yeah yeah he's only making this
party worse for himself yeah and so it's like
yeah again it's like the structure I'm impressed
but then I'm also like okay but but now I'm
back to what I'm used to from the character
which is always great which is always one
of the best parts of both of these movies
is he is he is like the casts of both of these
are so great and he is a perfect Center piece
because he is like kind of transcendent as
this guy like he just breathes this character
and so I'm not disappointed by that but I
feel like yeah if they had maintained some
of that fish out of waterness or at least
some element of that personal need for the
case throughout the movie that could have
maybe made it just yeah emotionally attached
or or you know kind of complete that interesting
thing they bring up for the first half you
know but overall I still I still really liked
it a lot and it's hard to follow up a movie
like Knives Out yeah and I cannot wait to
see what the next one is yeah oh yeah that's
another thing I would blindly chop at the
bit and be excited for a part three yeah because
what I like I like that this is like they've
given in the dissection of both these movies
they were just different things to appreciate
and different things where I'm like okay this
could have been a little bit more whatever
for me uh and so yeah it's it's nice to have
a situation where you know eventually you'll
have a preference one over the other but to
me they're sort of neck and neck because they're
both doing something that is knives out but
that there is unique to each installment and
that kind of adds to that lovely you know
murder mystery novel quality where yeah it's
like you don't need to there are certain like
serial elements of puero stories I think but
I don't think you necessarily have to read
them all in order or anything like that I
think this is shaping up to be nicely that
way you could peer in on any Blanc mystery
and pick your favorite because everyone's
gonna have a different favorite you know well
guys what did you think about Glass Onion
did you like it more than the first did you
like it just as much are you kind of disappointed
what's your thoughts subscribe leave a like
last but not least to send us for the patreon
Mikhail knew it for some reason I was like
yeah
because I imagine this you wind yourself into
a situation of grave proportions and you need
someone to crack the case and come out who
would make you feel the most comfortable look
at mikhail's profile picture and tell me that
if that dude showed up in a snazzy suit with
his Spectacles on you wouldn't be like no
I gotta I gotta listen to this Swedish guy
he knows what he's doing and he can crack
Decay he's a sophisticated he's seen every
James Bond movie he's gonna be ahead of the
curve on all these Mysteries and World rending
plots and whatnot and plus he's a good guy
he's been here forever you see Mikhail it's
like being greeted with a warm southern accent
except you know not that because he's not
from Louisiana and I feel like you're you're
a nice analogy for a movie like this and I
love you and I hope that you continue to Grace
our patreon page for ages and Evers and I
hope you're having a good holiday season buddy
I am Merry Christmas and happy New Year buddy
[Music]